derrière le comptoir de la librairie
lettres voisine située à voisins le
bretonneux et ouverte en mai 2003 se
trouve christine sauvage sa gérante
elle réside dans la ville nouvelle
depuis 1977
ça m'a permis quand même deux des
contacts avec un lectorat très
diversifié aussi bien des jeunes des
scolaires des tout petits
et puis des adultes et des gens aussi
très très bon lecteur très pointue dans
leurs demandes au fond de la boutique le
coin des enfants chers à la libraire
fans d'albums jeunesse d'enfants peuvent
regarder alors je me bats pour qu'aucun
livre ne soit par terre parce qu'un
livre c'est précieux initialement en
kiné christine sauvage décide de
s'orienter vers des études de lettres
elle a travaillé pendant dix ans aux
pavés du canal et du grand plaisir elle
est devenue enseignante dans un dut
métiers du livre elle apprenait la
constitution d'une librairie et la
comptabilité d'un commerce en fête pour
expliquer les choses à mes étudiants
c'était de créer moi-même ma librairie
dans un endroit où il n'y avait
pratiquement pas de librairie et moi mon
objectif c'était de faire cette cette
librairie de proximité
christine sauvage et passionnée elle a
fait déplacer de nombreux auteurs elle
se souvient notamment de jumelles âgées
de 8 ans venue voir l'auteur perf dans
sa librairie et récemment
eh bien j'ai une de ces jeunes filles
maintenant qui est arrivé avec son papa
elle venait de se marier et elle m'a dit
vous avez toujours des livres de bef
incitions bien sûr à son tour cette
jeune femme ne pourra pas venir chercher
un exemplaire pour son enfant suite à
des embûches lettres voisine va fermer
les difficultés sont venues d'une part
de nos fournisseurs quand même il faut
le dire
j'avais au cours des années mais remise
diminué parce que je n'avais pas un
volume suffisant d'achat on a des
charges qui sont assez importante par
rapport à notre marge brute des gens qui
s'engagent dans la librairie staff qui
utiliseront pas des salaires mirobolants
mais de là à se retrouver
vraiment trop trop juste et ça a été un
des plus gros problème qui a été vu par
le repreneur en fait les représentants
en diminue la concurrence de la vente en
ligne progresse la libraire déplorent
les charges minime pour les grands
groupes
même avec notre syndicat des libraires
de france on n'a pas la force l'impact
nécessaire pour faire face à ce genre de
deux concurrents stenbeck parmi les onze
mille ouvrages dans la librairie des
cartons le déménagement est proche c'est
le coeur lourd qu'un chapitre se termine
pour christine sauvage je regrette
vraiment pour voisin que cette librairie
ferme parce que pendant longtemps on a
cru que ça allait continuer et que
d'autres prennent le relais la librairie
lettres voisine fermera le 31 janvier à
moins qu'un repreneur se signale